We have a voicemail number.
That number is 2 1 9 2.
David P..
Here is our old friend, Troy york.., who is
very triggered by the discussion of Donald
Trump's IQ.
And he wants Dr. Foushee arrested and the
impact.
Now, who's watching your video?
We have a caller, the female caller who bashed
President Trump saying he has a low IQ and
asking you leontine.
Thank you.
This is Troy Yorkin.
I think that woman's IQ was 66 and I think
years is seventy five.
And actually, you are in and have deep pockets,
deep state and communist China.
Right.
Trump has done a great job.
He needs.
Overall, he's authoritarian.
Leaders in the blue states who have tried
to wreck our economy for political power and
because they hate Trump serves and I think
that President Trump will over roll these
stay at home waters hails a disaster for our
economy.
Think Dr. Anthony Fauci should be arrested
for treason, faulty and basically.
This has been a concentrated campaign, I believe,
from the far left to discredit and once again
attack this country and capitalism.
Right.
So they're so so that when when we talk about
confident, weaponised arrogance and ignorance,
that's what we're talking about.
Arrest Foushee.
This is all a left wing plot.
You've got a 75 IQ.
That's what we're talking about.
And that's someone who.
I mean, it's really a case study no matter
what.
That's someone who's voting for Trump in November,
no matter how many deaths happen as a result
of Trump's action.
So that's what we're fighting against and
that's why get out the vote rather than argue
with people.
Is the strategy that we must employ.
Let me remind you, Thursday, April 9, membership
explosion one day membership special were
down like 75 members already in April.
We lost three eighty nine in March because
of the virus.
We are putting together a one day huge membership.
Special email will go out on Thursday, April
9th to be notified.
All you need to do is get on our newsletter.
OK.
Go to David Pakman dot com on the Web site.
You type in your e-mail address.
You're on the newsletter.
Thursday, 2:00 p.m. Eastern, 11:00 a.m.
Pacific, you will get that beautiful, beautiful
e-mail.
And of course, membership includes the bonus
show.
Coming up right after this.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot com.